Để góc phần vào thành công dục của đại hội đại biểu tăng Quốc lần thứ mở bốn của đam.
Không thể không nhắc đến với trò quan trọng của báo chi trong tông tác không tìm tình tình chuyển như lỗi dùng quan trọng của đại hội tự rồi dân cả nước.
Chúng tâm báo chi, nơi làm việc của gần bẩy chăm nhà báo, không viên, ký thuật viên của các cơ quan thông tính,
báo chi trong nước và gút tế tham gia nưu tìm về đại hội đảng tọn Quốc lần thứ mở bốn.
Để đảm báo công tác thông tìm, ký thuên về đại hội đường thông xuất, chính xác và ký thời.
Phong viên các cơ quan báo chi được tạo được kịch tốt nhất về cơ sở vật chất,
trong thêm bị đại hội hội hội.
Chúng tâm báo chi được báo chi đại đủ các thiết bị, phương tịnh kiết thuật cùng hệ thống đường
chuyến internet chức luật tốt, tạo được kiến thận lợi tối ra cho khoa chiến tắc nghiệp báo chi.
Sơn định đại hội mề bố làm một sự kiện chính xịnh đặc miệt quan trọng,
nhưng người làm báo tự chung hương để điệu phương đều dọ cho những những trong việc chuyến tài lông tìm điện trọng,
nhưng cũng phải chính xác và đại đủ mề sự kiện này.
Được ra nhiều vụ thì đây là một cái thuy nhất là vinh dự,
ra vào một cái trọng trách rất là lớn và chúng tôi là phải tập hợp.
Một lộn mũ các kỳ sơ kỳ thuật viên,
có cái chính đổ chuyến vôn cao để làm mạo làm sao mà vật thành tòa nộn cái hệ thống.
Các bạn thích bị tốt, ra mạo được cái mà vật thành nó chương trụ.
Trong tất cả các cái thời gian là đại hội.
Ngoài đúng cũng phòng viên trong nước.
Con có khoảng bài mới chính phòng viên nước ngoài và trở lý các văn phòng báo chi nước ngoài
đang ký tham dự nước tìm đại hội.
Đâm hơi, bộ ngoài ra không đám ở mới bài phòng viên.
Trong đó, có bà phòng viên người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài đưa tìm sự kiện.
Chức tiết tham dự nước tìm về đại hội.
Các phòng viên kêu bào thể hiện chắc nghiệp và tâm miến có phần lăng toàn thông tin chính thống.
Cái nối đại hội với cộp đồng người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài.
Mấy cái chức nghiệp và cái trứ cách là không viên bảo viên nước.
Là kêu bào của Việt của người Việt nước, về gian án, thì chúng tôi cảm thấy rằng mình cần phải chức nghiệp.
Bảy mắm sạch tại hội, đưa nhận ký thông tin của đại hội.
Cái tuần nhất cũng muốn như những gì đây để làm lăng toàn xác tục đục tế.
Một hình anh để làm, không hà bình khắp trên.
Và được việc là dầu vẫn khóa và rất mến khác.
Sự trình bịn chứ như chú đảo về mọi mặt.
Sự tham ra hương của nước đảo, cơ quan trường trong nước và cúc tế để hợp phần.
Công của đại hội đăng lên trường mề bún.